Hello everybody, this is Dr. Collar, again, and I'm going to talk about how do I diagnose my disease?
How do I know what I have going on in my body?
Probably one of the reasons why you took this course. You might already know you have an auto view disease and
You want to figure out what are the triggers?
What are the causes? What are was the original antigen? What is the what is the how do I deal with this now?
You might not know you have a this is out of you disease. You might you know
Be thinking on one light or the other or you might be right
We want to get into this disease. First, I have to understand that
We do not diagnose so this course the purpose of this course is not to diagnose and or is the purpose of this course to treat disease
So we're not diagnosing and we're not treating disease, but we are here to help you
Take this information to your functional practitioner. Take this information to utilize it yourself
I just believe we're in an era where we have to know how to take care of ourselves
And that's what our courses. That's why I designed all our courses and how you can best take care of yourself take care of your family
You know, one of my mentors said I remember years and years ago said he looked at his little daughter
And he goes it's not really as if he's asking is she ever going to have an auto immune disease
It's really what auto immune disease is she going to have and how he's got to figure out how to manage it
Because we're living in a society where we're exposed to so many poison so many toxins so many antigens and our body
Just cannot handle and we can end up developing antibodies
Again self tissue because of that exposure. That's what we're going to dig into in this entire course
And remember it's a living course. I'll be adding videos and information as we go and ability for you to test and and you can take this
Information back to your local practitioner whether it be a naturopath or chiropractor or medical doctor who's trying to do more
Functional things and say hey, can I get these tests? Can you evaluate this way?
I understand and you have to have a little bit of mercy on your practitioners
They're overwhelmed too to dig into learning this material not everybody's you know bent that way and
So you might have to do the education yourself to help them along in their understanding
So this through this course, we're going to go through a flow of what I think is a proper self-care
Proper self-way to evaluate yourself proper way to
To to make better decisions in your life and deal with these chronic conditions that you are a family member have that you just can't seem to overcome
We're going to go through starting at the beginning educating yourself. That's what these modules are for
Never underestimate lifestyle management and what that could do and not making the mistake that it's we're just one
Supplement away from curing ourselves
Looking at dietary testing and managing that is really key because those are a major source of antigens
That can be stimulating immune responses at any time you've stimulated immune response
That's a hyper immune response when you have antibodies this self tissue
You're going to kill that what you have antibodies against first
That's rule number one at any autoimmune disease
So and then testing and dealing with possible antigens the understanding the the seven phases of detoxification and chemical detox
chemical toxicity
Understand how to heal your barriers
Managing your immune tolerance and dealing with flares of your immune system and
Understanding more than anything. It's not a matter of your making an autoimmune disease go away
You're not going to ever be sure from it. It's about managing it
It's just like you're not going to ever get rid of toxicities in your life. You're going to learn how to manage it
You're never going to get we live in a fallen world you have to you know grasp that and where managing our
Walk through this fallen world and if you can if you can understand it that way
You're not going to get so down on yourself when you have flares and you're and you don't feel good
When you you know work through so many things and you started to feel better
You're going to go through ups and downs. That's the way it is in life
Really when we look at autoimmune
Disorders and I and I steal this slide in several of my slides from
Dr. Karatsian who was one of my mentors in such a great
Understanding of autoimmune disease. There are so many factors of autoimmune disease
So there's so many things to deal with that's why it's going to be an education kind of of drinking from a fire host
Call through this course
But the more that you can listen to this and digest it and break it down the better
We're going to have issues with depressed white blood cells
We're going to have issues with active infections and this will come and go with a person with autoimmune
How does an autoimmune patient that has antibodies to self tissue deal with an active infection?
Oh my gosh, I got some active viral infection or bacterial infection that can flare
Everything up and when you're trying to kill that active infection that can flare everything up
How do you deal with barrier permeability? That's a huge piece that we have to deal with because when you have permeability of intestinal barriers or lung barriers
And you're exposed to things that cross that barrier now it becomes an antigen it will flare
At th1 reaction in your body and then you will kill that which you have antibodies against first which is self tissue
Overactive phagocytic cells and we'll talk more about that in other videos
loss of complement protein function your complement proteins are like landmines in your body that are going to be
Stimulating immune response. You know kill things
In themselves, but they stimulate an immune response to kill things
You can measure your complement proteins if those are auto balance that will give you suggestions
Of how to deal with this immune response
And abnormal T cell differentiation. This is measurable as far as a test goes as well
That's so necessary, but you can measure that
dysfunction in immune cell function
This is a huge piece of autoimmune disease and a huge
Huge piece of why a person has a problem and a huge piece of how you can help manage it
Your regulatory t cells help balance that th1 th2 response
And when a person is an autoimmune flare, they're almost always in a hyper th1 response
And can be stimulating a death of self tissue in this inflammatory response at that self tissue site that you have antibodies
for and
And stimulating your t-reg cells can help comb that doubt and balance that that's a huge piece of
Care for an autoimmune disease happens to be helping to increase
Regulatory t cells where they're also called t-reg cells. I may say that at different times
We want to look at chemically-induced immune dysfunction. We want to test for that. Do I have chemical toxicity issues
We certainly don't want to be detoxing them without understanding the seven phases of detoxification
That's a whole other course, but you could download the book on my website for free
Understand chemical binding to tissue proteins. That's a whole other piece. We think of oh, I have you know
glyphosate toxicity and that's my problem
But it gets worse of that because you can have chemicals that actually bind to proteins
In your body and create an entirely new antigen. That's called a neoantigen and you can actually develop antibodies to that
Oh, it gets even worse and
Abneural microbiome. That's your gut microbiome and your
All your all your tissue microbiome not just your gut
And then the psychodural immune promotion that has to do with the neurology of your immune response
Your parasympathetic sympathetic balance that is so key everything we seem to talk about with
Disease and natural healing and autoimmune disease really has to do it seems like we're always talking about chemistry, right?
We're talking about oh, well this these blood tests are often you have antigens to this tissue
We're all this is all chemistry molecular biology
But we forget that everything is controlled by our neurology
So our neurology of our immune system is our parasympathetic sympathetic
This is the autonomic nervous system control of our immune response
And our detoxification response and when we're under a hyper stress situation
Like everybody is all the time
We end up with a hyper stimulated sympathetic nervous system
A depressed or suppressed
parasympathetic nervous system is our parasympathetic nervous system that literally controls
Our immune function and balances our immune function and controls our detoxification pathways
And then we're going to talk about braid injuries and what that can happen just traumas to our braid and what that does to our immune response and how
Damage to our
Neural tissue what's called micro glial primate can be a huge factor in autoimmune disease
You could even develop with
A concussion so you might not even have any toxicity exposure you might not have
Any foods issues any barrier issues
Well, I don't think anybody has none of these but I'm just pretending and you could have suffered a concussion or multiple mild concussions
You never even got knocked out as a child and you have micro glial primate braid tissue damage
Causing damage to the blood brain barrier causing
Antibodies to be formed against neural tissue
This is this is way more common that you could ever imagine and this can lead to complete
Disaster in a person's life. So we got to go into that in detail
So we're going to learn about all that how to diagnose that yourself
We don't have to diagnose but how to understand that and to identify that so you can start
Walking through the lifestyle changes that you need to walk through
Here's the picture of a barrier change with the tight junctions in your gut
Everybody's heard of leaky gut right anybody on this you know listening to this slide presentation
It's heard of leaky gut, but there's barriers throughout your body
When you get
antigens that get in your body that shouldn't be in your body
maybe it's a toxin maybe it's um
a
You know a biotoxin you end up developing
antigens
Though these are antigens and you end up developing
Fire in an immune response and that immune response will kick in a TH1
immediate immune response and then a TH2
um
B cell response and that B cell response is how you create antibodies and if you're if it's like a toxin or
Heavy metal or something like that you can't create antibodies against that if that thing settles in your tissue
You can create antibodies against that tissue and that's how we develop an auto immune disease
So antigens in our body create fire in immune response
Over and over this takes place and this has to do with damage barriers. It has to do with exposure to toxins
Has to do with traumas head traumas especially and then we create antibodies to self tissue and it's these antibodies
That aren't really the culprit. So when we have antibodies to self tissue
We will we technically have an auto immune disease. That's what an auto immune disease when we have antibodies to self tissue
But it could be a different stages. We could have multiple auto immune diseases. We do we could have
multiple tissues in our body that have antibodies against them
But there are different stages. So the stages of auto immune disease again. I have a whole video of this as
Stage one really silent auto immunity. I really don't know that I have anything
I don't have related symptoms, but I do have elevated antibodies
But no real symptoms. Maybe I have elevated thyroid antibodies. Maybe I've elevated rheumatoid antibodies to my joint capsules
But I don't really have any joint issues that I could even think of. I don't have any swelling then stage two
Now those elevated antibodies start to cause some symptoms. No critical
Notice some tissue loss me that I don't have any swelling in my joints, but they're just stiffer
I don't know. Maybe it's just getting old
I'm not sure and then stage three I have elevated antibodies with symptoms
And now measurable tissue damage. Wow. My joint is really swollen now
I just can't move it quite as much. What is going on with my joint? I can't figure out what that is
You're in stage three auto immune disease wouldn't it be great if we could catch these things earlier
Because you can make lifestyle changes many times when we get to stage three
Let's say in my joint example
I can already have damage to the articular cartilage of the joint and that it may be irreparable
So if we could catch these things at an earlier stage and not just dismiss them as you know, I'm getting older or whatever
We're going to be better off
So a lot to go through right a lot to understand
So how do we know how?
Again, that's why I took this course all right, you know, tell me how do we get to this
Well, you hopefully have a practitioner where you can get a good medical history
But do we your own medical history, you know
The first thing we talk about is where is the rest of the auto immunity meeting that there's other things going on
so
Just because I have
Hashimoto's and then but diagnosed with Hashimoto's do I have any systemic
Issues any systemic auto immunity you want to measure that and there's blood tests that you can
You can run to get these things measured
Are there dietary triggers
This is before you even do any blood work you start asking yourself these questions
Boy, yeah, you know what I what I eat this I just don't feel as well
um
That's a side that you you know if you are reacting to a food
It is most likely the protein in the food that you're reacting to why would you possibly react to a protein in that food
Because you have antibodies to that protein
so
You're in this early stages of autoimmune disease
So if you have dietary triggers you don't feel as well when you eat this thing and you can pinpoint some of these dietary triggers
It's pretty good side. We need to dig into this. Do you have lifestyle triggers?
Boy, I can't really walk into a room
With um, you know, smoking that room that would be a chemical trigger as well
Or I just you know when I'm under a lot of stress. I seem to fall apart
when you know
Look at your life and be introspective and are there different dietary chemical lifestyle triggers
Antigenic triggers
That can suggest that you have damaged barriers that you can suggest that you have antibodies to different things
That are stimulated in immune reaction. They're stimulated inflammation
Um, that's what we want to look at and understand what is the degree of this immune tolerance
Can I tolerate a lot of situations? Can I tolerate a lot of environments that I really don't have any flares
That's the way we want our body to function if we have a fairly low degree of immune tolerance
We tend to crash in different situations
Then we want to dig deeper
Then we get to a physical exam are there neurological changes
Getting to a functional neurologist to get literally examined
um
cerebellar or upper motor neuro
Cortex issues
Can be key catching those early can be really key to decreasing
Um to a deal with or the decrease in the inflammation that could be causing this do I have joint issues
Don't dismiss these as just old age things do I have swollen lymph nodes commonly do I have swollen tonsils look yourself in the mirror
Do I have nodules on my thyroid do I have vascular changes like radiance disease or do I get really
cold feet to my hands get cold a lot at night do I have signs of male absorption
Do I have pulmonary lung issues can I take a really deep breath and take a you know couple really deep breaths really quick
And I have no issues or does it make you cough or make you kind of you know
You just feel it your lungs and that's a side
Right there that
There's some ill health going on in the lung tissue
So these are the things that you want to examine and find a good practitioner that will do a good physical exam on you
And really look at these things. It's hard to find somebody that will really do that
But you need to be introspective as well
And then you can dig into the laboratory things just routine labs can be extremely beneficial to look at autoimmune disease and other things that are going on
Then you can get a defunctional medicine labs and different specific antibody screens like the Syrexyl A5 or the Ray 7 or the Ray 7x
Those are good arrays that get into just measure antibodies. If you want to know you have an autoimmune disease
You can see it right there
The routine labs that everybody should be getting done by their practitioner is your complete blood count
Um that includes ferritid
CRP and ESR as well
Most people are not going to get complement protein test done
But you can ask for those. They're not super expensive
Most people will not get T and B blood T and B cell lymphocyte
Profiles
They could be a little bit more expensive too
But the but if you went just for a regular regular physical
Checkup they would do a complete blood count and a which is a CBC
And they would do a complete metabolic panel which you would get ferritid C-reactive protein
And all your markers for your liver markers those are good things to get done
Then you can get if if the practitioner suspects an autoimmune disease there are certain autoimmune biomarkers that you can get run
I get ANA test, anti-DNA test, a rheumatoid factor
And then if you want to get specific tissue antibodies typically like a thyroid profile
You might get TPO or Thyro-globulin antibodies tested in a complete thyroid profile
Those are some ways that you can look at those tests and get some
Some understanding of ill-health or imbalance in any of those tests
I will do want to say that the ranges on the routine lab tests that come back from the lab are really wide
From a functional standpoint you got to take that range and cut it down
Because from a functional standpoint we want to look at a tighter range
And if it's outside of that tighter range it gives us clues that things are going on
Any lab test remember they're all just clues of what's going on
And then the functional medicine tests you can do barrier tests with different
Cyrex panels
You can do dietary protein tests and I'm going to have videos on all these different tests
That you can see on
This course so that array two goes into the very specific
Test the barriers the gut barriers
The array cyrex array 20 tests the blood-brained permeability test
Very important
Because your blood-brained permeability is that leaky brain issue is
Is very underrated you're getting things that are crossing into the brain that shouldn't be crossing into the brain
You're going to cause inflammation of the brain and
Nothing good can happen from that
So we're exposed to remember you got circulating toxins in your body that your ancestors never even
Saw before and you do not want them getting into the brain
That will cause microglial damage and it's going to cause all sorts of problems
Dietary protein tests are very underrated and you have to do
These I'm convinced through Cyrex
I make nothing off the Cyrex lab
They're just the best out there
So you want to make sure you're doing the Cyrex array three if you're if you're already like hey
I'm already gluten intolerant
I stay away from gluten I stay away from dairy and cross
Reactive foods then just running the Cyrex 10 to make sure there isn't any other foods that you're reactive to because if you're
Reacted to foods understand you're firing an immune response and you're our
Causing inflammation and fire in the gut and in the body and in the brain every time you eat that food
So you want to really clear that up
There's different chemical tests that we could do. How much a different chemical test?
There's different pathogen tests we could do there's different
GI function tests that we could do there's environmental tests we could do and then down at the bottom of this is the autoimmune
antibody
Screen and I listed a array
Five on there, but the Cyrex array
Seven is for brain antibodies of the seven X's expanded
Antibodies if you're having a lot of upper motor to run brain issues
emotional issues
Just weird issues that many live patients have that you know
It's just in different parts of the body at different times which is a suggestion of microglial
Private a suggestion of inflammation of the brain. It's good to get that array seven X tested as well
Now I know you shouldn't be doing these all at once
But this is there this is what you see in the Cyrex array five. This is absolutely normal
There's no antibodies present in there, but with that these are what you're actually measuring the pridele cell
um
Antibodies are antibodies that are causing intrinsic factor. They're
affecting the stomach autoimmunity gastric autoimmunity and you can see this list going all the way down
So these are the ways that you can measure. How do I diagnose my disease?
How can I bring this information to my practitioner and say hey can can I run this test?
You can run the test through our clinic right now as well
You'll see a button where you can get the test done as well
But you can get a practitioner that could run this test and help you through this to again
We're here to educate you
We want you to to have the best
Knowledge moving forward and why you should
How you should take care of yourself and really dealing with autoimmune disease
You're gonna hear me say over and over again
Then it's all about understanding self tolerance in autoimmunity
Different pollutants different toxins different chemicals different hormonal changes different stresses in our life
Molecular chemistry immune issues diet from dietary
proteins biotoxins cause
Immune dysregulation and we have a decrease
Self tolerance. We're exposed to a lot of these things. We're just beat up and our immune system can't handle it
It's overwhelming the what T reg cells and we get an immune imbalance
And this is how we end up with a production of self tissue antibodies antibodies to our own cells
We start off with a silent immunity. We end up it going to a full
Stage three autoimmune disease with tissue damage
And it's about controlling this immune response
And controlling our exposure to these things so that we can live in a world where there are pollutants and toxins and where we do have stresses
And where we do have infections that we have to deal with and our immune system is strong enough to be able to tolerate that
That's what we're talking about
You know helping you walk through this to help you strengthen that ability to tolerate these things in our life
Hopefully this video was helpful maybe you have to listen to it a couple of times but
We'll continue with you know
Get into all these different diagnostic procedures and understanding these tests in more depth as well. All right. Thanks so much. Bye. Bye